if you invest four thousand dollars in a
mutual fund that earns three percent
annual interest compounded monthly
how much money would you have after five
years and they give us the compound
interest formula is a is equal to p
times 1 plus r over m and all of that to
the mt power and you could we could just
apply this by plugging in these numbers
but i one thing i do want you to realize
is that this is not just some magical
formula it's actually very very
straightforward to derive and it's
actually a common sense form i think
that's important because when you have
to figure this out when your mutual fund
manager is talking to you you probably
won't have this formula at hand or even
if you do have this formula you have to
know when it makes sense and when it
doesn't make sense and to show that this
is actually fairly straightforward just
think about what happens if i start with
four thousand dollars if i start with
four thousand dollars and i compound it
once at three percent so here when they
say compound monthly what they're really
saying is
every month you get to compound your
money you get to grow your money by one
twelfth of three percent but let's say
we have a where we have a we have a
reality where we're compounding annually
so let's say compound
compound annually
so that means every year you get three
percent more than the money that you had
going into the year compounding annually
so you're going to start with four
thousand dollars and then after one year
you're going to get three percent of
four thousand dollars so point zero
three times four thousand dollars this
is after one year this is the same thing
as four thousand dollars times if you
factor out the four thousand one plus
0.03
so you have your original principal
amount and if you compound once annually
you get that times 1 plus your actual
annual interest rate now if you were to
compound annually five times you would
then compound this by one plus .03
times one plus zero point zero three and
the only reason why i'm not just writing
one point zero three is so that you see
how it relates to this formula they're
giving to you and if you're going to if
after two years if you compound annually
you'll do it again and again so really
after if you do it for five years you're
gonna multiply this times one plus point
zero
three five times so if you compound
annually at
three percent
over five years over five years
then you're actually just looking at
four thousand dollars
times one plus zero point zero three
to the fifth power
and i think you already see this is how
much you would have left after five
years
so this is what you would be left with
and i think you can already see the
pattern relative to this formula you
have your original principal amount four
thousand dollars you have the one over
here you have your rate
over here we didn't we don't have any m
because we're compounding annually m is
the number of times you compound per
year and once again we just have the
time five years and over here in this
case you could just say that m is equal
to one so let me write this this is the
case where m is equal to one let's think
about what happens if we compound every
six months because i really want you to
get the intuition for this formula
compound
compound every six months or you could
say
or you could say twice a year
so you start off with four thousand
dollars after one six month period how
much you're going to have well every six
months you're going to compound half of
three percent since we're compounding
twice a year each period you get half of
the annual interest rate so after one
six month period you'll have one plus
0.03 over two after another six month
period you'd compound that again
zero point zero three over two and so
how many six-month periods are we going
to have well five years has ten six
month periods so this is going to be
equal to
4 000
times 1 plus 0.03
over 2
to the we have five years each of them
have two periods two times five power
and now you see it directly we our a our
principal
is right over here it's four thousand
dollars
our
annual interest rate is r it is three
percent in either circumstance
and the number of times we compound per
year
is m
now let me do that in a new color it is
m the number of times we compound per
year is m in this case right over here
it is two and then the number of years
the number of years that we are doing
some compounding is t right over there
so hopefully this formula makes sense
and you see it's not just coming from
from some financial voodoo it actually
comes straight from common sense but
with that out of the way let's think
about the actual question if we invest
four thousand dollars in a mutual fund
so unless we want to solve
if you invest four thousand dollars in
the mutual fund
so now let's think we're going to
compound
compound
12 months
or or we would say 12 times
12 times per year
because because we are compounding
monthly every month our money will grow
by 1 12 of 3 percent so it's going to be
4 000 times 1 plus
1 12
of 3 percent
and then we're going to do that to the
number of years times the compounding
periods per year so we have 12
compounding periods per year times the
the number of years and just to see
where it all fits in
this right over here four thousand
dollars was our principal that goes
right over there that is p in our
formula our rate is three percent that
is r in the formula and hopefully the
formula makes sense to you now
m
the number when they say compounded
monthly they're telling us that we are
compounding 12 times a year
compounded let me do that in that right
color
compounded monthly this tells us that m
is equal to 12.
m is equal to 12
right over there and there and then we
are doing it over five years
we are doing this over five years that
is our t
that is our t right there and now we can
just get a calculator out to actually
evaluate this
let's see we have got my trusty ti 85
out we're going to have four thousand
dollars is what we're starting with
times
times one
plus
and then we have zero
or we could just write point i'll just
write the zero out front just to be
clear zero point zero three
divided by twelve so that's how much
we're going to compound every month
every month and then all of that to the
12 times 5 power and actually let me
make it clear that
whoops let me make it
clear that
we want to do the order of operations so
let me insert a multiplication sign
and then let me raise everything in
parentheses
to the
to the 12 times 5 power or to the 60th
to the 60th power it might seem like a
very huge exponent and it is but
remember you're taking one plus a very
small number to the sixtieth power one
of the sixtieth power would just be one
the closer you get to one the the more
times you can take its power without
becoming a really huge number but we
wanna be clear we wanna take this to the
sixtieth power before we multiply by
four thousand
and we get four thousand six hundred and
forty six dollars and forty-seven cents
let me put this over the side so i can
read it
so this gives us
this gives us if we invest our money and
this is what's pretty neat the three
percent compounded compounded monthly
three percent annual interest actually
does add up to a good bit over just five
years three percent doesn't seem that
exciting but adding
4
646 so adding 646 dollars to 4 000 that
does actually seem pretty exciting and
if we round up 47 cents is what you
would have in your account after five
years